On the surface, creating a list of items
is simple enough.
Android includes a ScrollView
into which you can place any linear layout
that in turn arranges each item
it contains into a vertical list.
Note the items which have fallen off
the bottom off the linear layout,
and therefore aren't
currently visible in that UI.
The ScrollView, as the name suggests,
will let the user scroll through
the contents of the layout it contains.
But there's a challenge
associated with that approach
on a device with limited memory,
and where touch responsiveness
is critically important.
If you have 50 items in a list and can
fit 10 items on screen at any given time,
what's the minimum number of views
you'd need to create
in order to scroll through
every item on the list?
The answer might not
be immediately obvious,
but think about ways in which
you can be more efficient
in your use of the views
used to display the entire list.